hello nice to see again thanks for
joining us today on this very very
special episode of the h3 podcast no
memes left behind first of all let me
welcome you all under the gazebo yeah
today on a very special up for the extra
podcast we'll be joined by Kidd the
producer in the intern ela the pregnant
[Music]
nomemes left behind today we are
sponsored by Skillshare now let me
explain what is going on today okay
throughout the year we've covered a lot
of stories we've talked about a lot of
things but there's always these great
gifts laughs and gaffes and booths even
I would even venture to say a couple of
booths that fall through the crack
they're great but we just didn't have
time to get to them
and so we've asked dan and Ian and ela
and even myself to go through all of our
documents over the course of the past
year and to salvage to save our fallen
meme brothers who have fallen behind
enemy lines and we've said no these are
fresh these are spooky these deserve to
be aired and so that is what we are here
to do today so today no meme will be
left behind and that's it so Ian and and
Dan would you join us please in the in
the office here in the studio so
introducing Dan of course yes
round of applause as a couple of Bob
donuts join us if you would please thank
you so much now Danny Ian now how long
have you guys been with this uh let's
see
it was first episode was uh you know
what the first episode was Joey salads
why did I think so how was that as like
you were I don't know if you were fans
of us but you knew who we were yeah no I
was a fan I watched the show or
the main channel pretty regularly so I
knew Joey's downs and that was
definitely that was definitely a weird
thing to step into but I think the
second week was steve-o which is [ __ ]
awesome yeah to get to meet him so I was
that was a good introduction and the
producer we cherish and love we were a
bit of a mess here and Dan was like a
great recommendation from somebody
through twitch right and so we're like
dude do you want to just work full-time
well yeah and the rest has been history
as they say and we're just about a year
ago well it was even longer summer it
was summer of 2017 so there you go time
flies man seriously flies that's crazy
and Ian of course the illustrious I want
to say the eternal intern reached out to
us has a great origin story Ian Ian was
reaching out to us even before we hired
then I think well I probably told the
story a couple times but it bears being
repeated because that we get a lot of
emails from people and our you know we
have a work with h3 email that's open to
the general public got a lot of requests
a lot of emails but Ian comes through
very respectable very eloquent and he
says hey you know what I would like to
be an intern for you and you must have
emailed us like 20 times like Shawshank
Redemption like remember when he was
writing the letter asking for library
funds that we keep checking in with us
cuz I know we'll need help but we can't
do it right now but we will so were you
a fan of ours Ian yeah yeah I was and I
really and I yeah I really kind of
harassed you guys I was basically you
know just you know bothering you
non-stop
now now was that a technique I have to
ask what did were you writing other
people similar emails because you had a
strategy I'm wondering people were you
you know not really out not really
actually because you know
you guys were we're the most open mm-hm
you know a lot of people just you know
trash recycle this email so you know you
guys were open like you said you said
keep trying so you know I did you kept
at it yeah well that's it that's a good
life lesson for all the people out there
that persistence is truly the key to
either success or prison depending on
where you are success yeah restraining
order one or the other it's good to know
the difference but not all of us have
that gift and he and I want to say has
been a treat a pleasure a joy we love
and so much
god bless Diana in turn he's not really
an intern anymore he's blossomed into so
much more
yeah my first episode was when Skippy
and John Smith I feel like things that
have like tamed since you guys we got to
get back into doing some more weird and
wild stuff but those were the days huh
persuaded Joey salads in over a year
well I'm looking forward to our
Christmas special this 21st right we're
gonna do another charity Christmas
special oh okay well yeah we're doing it
with Justin roiland Alex Hirsch and Dana
Terrace
Terrace saying it right that's right
yeah I think you're right I don't I
blanked
but anyway from the last and Joey salad
so we're trying to think how can we you
know involve Joey salads in this and we
were thinking well we already pepper
sprayed him maybe we can shoot them with
a non-lethal beanbag and of course
Justin will have to be the one to pull
the tray ya know the twenty first mark
it down on the calendars boys we're
gonna do a lot of good this year and
that would be the last episode before
yeah yes yes yes well guys here we are
gathered today at the podcast table and
we have a lot of weird beer yeah being
in here you guys like being in here or
do you not like being in here it's I
don't know I definitely prefer to be
behind the scenes yeah but it's okay Ian
do you like your airtime oh I'm having a
panic attack
like you like the air I think I'm a
camera no you're not a hawk you're not
but nobody no means a hog what I mean
you know you you're you're you you have
a presence on camera yeah you have
natural charisma I always think that is
like more like me mmm it's subtle it's
subtle don't work you know it's subtle
panic attack yeah I don't I don't mind
it sure yeah you love it we slam that
handle of whiskey right before we came
in here so we have together I I will go
first I have what I call the Turkish
food segment and this is one yes that I
have personally been working on for a
long time you guys have been working
along with me to collect these videos
yeah the whole world out there on
Instagram I was browsing the Explorer
tab and you know they've got this
algorithm so when you click one video
then they know to show you more like it
when I started watching these incredible
Turkish chefs doing stuff that I have
never seen done with food before and I
went down this crazy rabbit hole of
Turkish Instagram cooking some amazing
some disgusting some hilarious at all
and I'm and I'm passionate about this
and I watch this to this day in fact I
saw one this morning that I'd like to
open up with that was completely
completely confused by and maybe you
guys can tell me what is this so tell me
what is this
I don't know what it is it looks like
egg he says penis what I clear yeah I
couldn't find open what looks like or
again but it looks like it's like dry
flour coming out of it I mean I don't
know what on earth well I was curious so
I translated the description always goes
great and um I'll read it for you guys
here
you know I'm Turkish never never doing
that yeah I've never seen the
translation says for 16 months and tripe
belly fat cheese open and tasted for the
wildlife it was quite heavy and couldn't
even stand the smell but a very special
and delicious cheese in general the
family's for consumption at home such as
pressing out the rumen would not
coincide I add this gets know that
clears it all yeah there's wildlife but
not what animal well it sounds like it
was fermented and an actual belly but I
love this mine I couldn't even stand the
smell very special but that being said
let's jump right into this Turkish food
yeah let's see what we have here so one
thing I've noticed because in Israel
obviously there's rules of kosher which
means you cannot mix meat and cheese but
the Turks almost in a way of being like
sucks to be Jewish they go all out on
the cheese and meat like even in America
I've never seen before take a look at
this I thought they were kosher in in
Turkey as well
well it's hello Dan is what al alright
and they actually halal you can mix meat
and cheese they cannot drink alcohol but
they they're not no they share a lot of
the similarities like they don't eat pig
right right yeah but they shell fish
yeah huh but they can do the dairy and
meat and so they are like god bless as
you should
they're like praise be to Allah we're
going all out with dairy and meat yeah
as you should so happy I never first of
all what is like this whole method of
cooking is bananas to me so that he
cooked it in like a pile of sand whoa he
takes out this unbelievably tender rack
the ribs
love the music measurement spider-man
and Elsa those bones slide right out I
mean this is a incredibly beautifully
cut piece of meat now here's where it
gets insane I don't know what this is
but he took ate what looks like ten
pounds of cheese and put it on each one
ten pounds of cheese on top and look
just without any great fit all sprinkles
a little imagine that I'll tell you
something right now
I would you guys are boring vegans but I
mean did you have respond to that did
your pulse increase weirdly I love me
but that completely made me not hungry
at all yeah I mean it's like a log of
food I don't like eating logs I would
definitely try that and you guys you you
find apps I imagine not
I don't know what's nauseous but I
probably would be nice as funding if you
could feel nice yeah great I mean yeah
I'm not vegan so I ate meat uh ten years
ago oh so it's it's been a minute I'm
deep in it yeah have you ever feel that
your will will break for a purpose yeah
occasionally and what is it attempts you
um you know weirdly seafood still is
like appetizing hmm
more so than
and it's weird because it's it's very
much just kind of baked in after a while
and certain things like any kind of pork
pig mm-hmm the smell of it it's like
makes me almost nauseous Oh like so bad
but like other meats like chicken not
bad at all like and that's not bad and
even beef for some reason pork in
particular it's gay nerd it's powerful
yeah
and it's and it's a somehow that the
Muslims and the Jews both were like we
can't eat that [ __ ] and so why did you
go vegetarian Dan originally for a girl
that I was dating the best reason
absolutely relationship really oh how
long are you vegan like six months I've
started to feel very ill did you
immediately bounce when you broke up
with her no I tried to keep it for a bit
but um you have to do it correctly
yeah so I was like oh well I'll just eat
some Cheerios cuz I don't know how to
cook ain't right there you know you got
it you have to have like a whole plan of
meals for you you become like
malnutrition yeah yeah yeah mmm look at
you how was that I mean was it worth it
for her was she good no no it wasn't
even worth it there's a good chance that
you guys will go on a diet at some point
in your life or off a diet because of
some dick or vagina so there you have it
but moving on this we're just in this is
just one video in to me I would you know
why don't you ever take cheesy shits on
my meat the way he just dumped the
cheese on there is something where he's
like aren't these amazing like like he's
like look at these amazing slow-cooked
ribs nope we're not done with it yet
boom
like seriously five pounds of cheese it
looks alive yeah well guess what
something's moving yeah Mike Nick gotcha
because I like it that much I'll do that
thank you thank you everybody thank you
for laughing and it told you me guys
appreciate that next they'll be left I
noticed so this one so sometimes what
they they make such an obscene amount of
food that it literally doesn't make
sense like I don't even know how he uses
all this so a restaurant I know but even
still like it is a restaurant yeah he
looks like he's on the old equals three
set that's true
Wow ray william johnson took a weird
twist in life so he flips upside down
with probably 20 or 30 pounds of food
food it frankly doesn't even look like
it belongs together but right off the
bone right off the bone this is their
move i know it's amazing like stocked up
early you hit that and what if it was
cooked to me yeah so if it's cooked in
me you're you're still down i mean it's
a great okay it's a great so the volume
is really kind of what fascinates me
here and such a good guy he's always
smiles all the time yeah do you know who
this guy is
can you like seek him out yeah it was
huge on instagram his videos got like
millions of years i feel like you got to
go to turkey some day and go eat it this
guy's right here to go to Turkey I don't
like Jews there but it's like gotten
worse or they don't like this really you
can go I can go no as a Jewish I can go
get some of this meat yeah how was your
trip to Turkey nice it's like going to
you know really yeah do you see any
crazy food and stuff turkeys pretty
secular I mean it's not no gotten more
no things are getting a little crazy
there yeah I hate regular stuff
nothing crazy hmm that's a shame similar
to Israel um okay so here you go this
your boy again all smiles sand I don't
know what it it looks like snow that
he's cooking his salt salt its salt look
at this look at that perfect look at
that smile look at that this guy's a
legend so it's a beautifully perfectly
cooked beef loin okay but wait before
they found out the spider-man Elsa music
hmm but wait my dude this was pretty
normal
yes look at this my goodness so there
you go I'm telling you these guys are
way over the top but it sounds like Mike
is almost rolling the American crowd
here's what you want to see right right
but it's Turkish people watching it it's
not Americans I'm the only American
watching this I swear to god it's all
Turkish the comments that's what I
thought too everyone's like Oh looking
up what these Americans eat and these
Turkish people are like like making us
look like amateurs yeah yeah I'm gonna
stop watching porn just watch when he
pours that cheese on that steak that's
enough to get me rock bird every time
what else we got this one is so weird
man I'm wondering what you guys are
gonna think about this so he starts with
the meat he's got a huge hammer okay
he's got a mallet like a massive hammer
and a witch's cauldron
so he's doing this classic little shake
meat off the bone
yes sir I don't know what's on the
bottom there but I'm down so now he
takes it though he's got meat and tomato
paste and a huge hammer and he's liquid
I he smashed it all into it looks like
yeah it looks like our refried beans
I've never seen cooking like this in my
whole life
so now somehow this chicken and meat is
turned into a paste and he's aligned the
bottom of a pan and now he's just
covering it with boiling oil like if you
told me there was meat in that I would
have no idea I mean what the hell was
yeah that one is that wild or what yeah
I don't know what it looks like you
could like it's like asphalt at the end
if you could pay for road with that but
you start with this really succulent
beautiful meat and then you just I and
then he pours like oil over it like but
it's fascinating
we've got more you guys don't here's
your boy he's the Sheep King I think he
mostly cooks lamb so he made this hit
for all of his fans on Instagram in the
world at large
seesee and yes everybody throw your
hands up cz and Barak I love how he's
like I may eat your [ __ ] head like
here is this his song yes this is a
original fit
[Applause]
by this guy's restaurant super famous
like on his Instagram I've seen the
parentheses the president of Turkey
there 18 celebrities and is writer 2 1
yeah I have no idea it just I followed
it I don't know what it is I really
don't dude if you type Turkish food
he'll pop up he's the God ro he's the
God look at him he's he's hurting the
sheep he's the guy you had like a little
Piper thing going on there yeah I'm
telling you this is a whole rabbit hole
but I'm not done yet because all my
adventures did you know that salt Bay
the original salt Bay is Turkish food
phenomenon right yeah he is probably
next to this guy the most famous his
videos get so many views I'm talking
like 12 20 million views on Instagram of
him doing slapping me Oh slapping the
[ __ ] out of me I have another sheep god
sorry it looks like a penis I mean this
[ __ ] is so wild woah yeah this is the
Sheep God look at this just sheep
carcasses and a giant sheep meat penis
in the middle I mean it's I never seen
anything like it in my life
the sheep Holocaust but it looks amazing
I mean that's pretty awesome oh yeah
yeah
that meat is like it's the presentation
is pretty unbelievable the way they cook
it and everything is so off the chain
that's something that one is actually on
the menu as sheep Holocaust and it's a
very popular dish especially in the
Middle East I love how he wouldn't when
you have like this super heavy nasty
dishes and you just sprinkle a little
like parcel on all to make it look fresh
there you have it I mean like if he set
that here I don't know what we do yeah
well he wasn't done the second part is
that he put
in a cauldron and beats it into a pace
that was that was a two-parter okay so
back to Salt Bay mm-hmm
so this ride like 1 million I [ __ ] you
not this video has 10 million on
Instagram of salt Bay sky I was kind of
I have to say a little bit disillusioned
when I saw salt Bay's actual content
because as you'll see in this video he
does not display the best cooking
prowess let's watch so he has a sausage
and spree rap
cuts it very dramatically heels off
Heidi rapping like he wants to [ __ ] it I
mean yeah now he takes a whole sauce
just cuts it in half okay I'm with it so
far really not thin to it and he just
throws it on the grill it's flapping it
together
flips it yep okay and here's of course
we're all good Turkish cuisine does tons
of meat doesn't not spread evenly not
even close to spread easily I mean not
even close
like not even close the whole left side
is no cheese on the right side is a nice
smashes it down and there you have it my
friend well that's it that's it yeah
that's it you didn't even cook what are
you doing so there you have it and the
Turkish flag oh that one I had me a
little perplexed after the lamb god I
yes is a letdown yeah it's like watching
like a straight-to-dvd sequel right yeah
I mean well gee whiz I feel like I've
done this exact meal when I was five
right take a hot dog cut in half and put
some cheese on it so there you have it
salt Bay in the flesh and one more that
I thought was pretty insane I'll share
with you from South Bay he has what
appears to be a beef mint or your whole
bottle you do it seems like he's doing
something he wears a dike actually I
heard he wears a diaper because he comes
in his pants
ten times a day when he comes to me I
think NiO fought him in the second major
about that so here he goes you know and
now after searing it he rolls it arose
it in gold flakes gold flake but really
that's those are gold flake the purpose
of that I have no idea and it does as
far as I can gold gold flashes medal the
precious metal yes Dan I bet it's very
well yes I don't think I've seen gold
flake dishes it's much less than it
appears and oh his plastic move like
Mortal Kombat the body so you know the
other guy makes him look like a tool
yeah no comparison yeah so there you
have it hmm Turkish cuisine I had no
idea
it's fascinating enough what that deep
so yes big big big I say those are the
two big boys in Turkish Turkish but
what's funny if you get into this rabbit
hole is that you'll find a bunch of
knock-offs who are doing so bad content
I'm trying to catch up with these guys I
was like guys who are just making a
falafel but they're trying to dance and
be sexy and it has like 20,000 views but
it's just it's great and they're trying
to do this smile like he's just making
falafels and he's got a big smile it's
great okay so there you have it there is
the segment extraordinaire up next in
has got something first should we take a
break we're at 3:30 oh yeah so after
this short break very short break ian is
going to grace us with people falling
off stage some celebrities so we have a
whole segment of celebrities falling off
stage during their performances is that
correct in yeah we got a few of those
hell yeah okay I'm very much looking
forward to that sounds like a lot that's
do not go away we will be right back
after this short commercial break
Skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes and
design business technology and
or you've got premium memberships that
give you unlimited access to
high-quality classes on must know topics
so you can improve your skills unlock
new opportunities and do the work you
love now many people play video games
and they grind and grind they grind so
you know get the highest level possible
but did you know you can do that in real
life you can grind and work on yourself
and you can level up and that's what
skill share is all about
they've got classes on every freaking
thing they've got oh for Mike situation
Adobe Suites After Effects premier
lighting DSLR cinematography so if you
want to make videos you want to be a
youtuber they've got everything you need
they get started and then on the other
end they've got like entrepreneur
classes they've got photography classes
everything I'm telling you you're gonna
level up with Skillshare and here's the
deal you can get an annual subscription
for less than $10 a month my dudes
since Scotia are sponsoring this video
the first 500 people to use the promo
link in the description will get their
first two months free to try it out
risk-free so hurry on down to the
description and click the link sk l dot
s h / h3 podcast that's sk l dot s h /
h3 podcast and the first 500 people to
use the promo code get first two three
months free sk l dot s h / h3 podcast
and we also have as you may notice these
beautiful luscious christmas sweaters
show it off your that's right work it
girl hmm we've got the classic VAP
nicholas design and introducing as
you'll see on our lovely model ela
always washing a faced at santa drinking
a soda pop and got h3 tatted on his nuts
all these sweaters come in green red and
gray over at represent calm / h3h3 we
also have the one meme one god virgin
ela sweater
here's the graphic there's only nine
days left nine days left guys is limited
right that's a low wish shredder the
actual virgin burst so here you go
head on over to represent calm slash
h3h3 and finally we are having a Teddy
fresh Black Friday sale mm-hmm
all kinds of summer stuff is on sale now
look at all this stuff up to 50% off
head on over to Teddy fresh calm slash
collection slash sale we got to do
something about that URL you can't
change that huh Shopify Teddy fresh calm
slash collection /l but you can just go
to the website and click the sales tab
hey we're back how did you do that okay
I was wondering how Daniel we're coming
back just not good we are back everybody
know meme left behind yeah yeah is your
duty to save a meme I don't remember who
kicked off the stage falling one did was
the I think the Janice just may have
been Kelsey Grammer he's gonna play it
from here
well I'm like we have audio from that
lap let's switch here yeah I should do
Kelsey Grammer we had put that video end
of the god babe Oh on the god babe right
okay well I've got that one here so let
me let me grab that here and I don't
believe we ever ever
anything I was a un in you should set
this up with a little bit with with some
contact yeah so he he was doing a speech
at Disney Disneyland I think or just
yeah wait it was Disney yeah or he was
at California Adventure all bad things
happen a small world
[Applause]
I love it so much
yeah the good Lord Ward yeah a big drop
he's pretty defeated about that huh
I've often wondered you know there's
this gag and Family Guy where Peter
holds his leg and goes yeah I've
wondered if this was in some way
inspired by this clip because he kind of
does that here yeah maybe
anyway when when did this this looks
like a really old friend yeah this is
classic
because like ten people to see oh good
lord
damn yeah I I didn't realize I was
digging around and kelsey Grammer's had
a very rough life Essie yes like very
dark
really like what his father was murdered
oh whoa and his sister was murdered
separate separate times random random
murders uh it was I think his father was
targeted by someone I read that but then
his sister was she was attacked by four
guys and they stabbed her and left her
to die and then both of his
half-brothers died in a scuba diving
accident yes yes whole family perished I
mean yeah all in different times of
years apart that is that is unbelievably
tragic I wouldn't leave the house if I
was him yeah and then there wasn't here
he is falling off the stage there was a
weird coincidence where the the name of
the guy who killed his father his last
name was Niles which is the name of his
oh the brother and rather in Frasier and
then the name of the guy who killed his
sister his name was was Freddie and his
son's name in Frasier's Freddie so it's
just the the two close characters came
in Frasier are named after is that a
proof that were in a simulation or see
the kissing thing well that is very
tragic thank you yeah yeah so gee-whiz
yeah it's kind of nuts how you can just
go through your life like take my life
for example
everything's great just you know we're
married you're gonna what you're about
to have a baby and then one day you
could just be stabbed and it's like you
know that's it and then you can also be
having a speech and fall off the stage I
mean anything could happen those two
things are about the same level yeah
here's another one that we had it's my
Donna this was at the BRIT Awards a few
years ago
[Music]
so what happened is the cave with the
fence because that car that's a month
horn or something apparently she was
supposed to take the cape off earlier
but it was noon I do tightly and she
couldn't get it off
wardrobe malfunction yeah let's see that
one again yeah that was that was quite
the tumble there does that mean she knew
it was coming
oh they're trying to get it off right
somebody pulled it someone yanked their
ass off the stage
the dancers are all pros they just like
keep going I think one of them may have
been trying to help her get it off mm oh
and he's yanked her ass off the stage
because he gave it a really good tug
like rock this cave yeah she uh she
responded to it she tweeted and said our
Monty hooked me up my beautiful cape was
tied too tight nothing can stop me and
love really lifted me up Zak I heard you
scream yeah right from the back nothing
can bring her down what did she say she
said well love lifted me up love lifted
her up Zak are you reviewing that
absolutely here's a Bieber one or gonna
fix his pants you set that up so I don't
thank you first of all yeah the who is
managing the stage and leaves a giant
hole in it I don't blame Bieber really
ya know those where you like show up
from Justin seems to be wearing 20
layers of clothing because I don't blame
him for not being able to good act it's
chilly in those big can we do that again
I was really
oh my god like it was a very nice Justin
Bieber or David Blaine see ya
[Applause]
you know I feel bad for the Biebs he
gets a lot of crap from everyone that's
just trying to do his thing and he's
just falling through holes and any more
information about that I'm fascinated by
that one uh he he tweeted out the video
and was just like I'm a cat I've got
nine lives lol okay there's a real like
he's like music
are you a big are you a B Bluebird oh
we've got we've we've got into it
Bugatti Biebs he's the best you are you
a family I like him I think he's got I
saw him on stage with post Malone and I
thought he was great yeah everyone
seemed really like super Tony's got a
great voice and he's got grace under the
when he's got grace you know I watched
videos of the paparazzi hassling him and
it get and it does give me a tremendous
amount of compassion for him and all the
stupid things he's done he's under a lot
of pressure pressure and expectation
he's always been like the guy he's so
famous like he's just trying to go
outside and live his life and TM seal it
and then and paparazzi just obsessively
follow this guy trying to push his
buttons and have been for years I mean
oh yeah it's like a child star right
yeah he's been family considering that
age where this all happened to him the
stuff that he's done that people don't
like him for is I don't think it's you
know that severe he's almost like a kid
making some mistake yeah well what has
he done that people are very upset about
he like peed and you like peed in a
bucket or something so big deal what
else he said I mean what you know yeah
guy oh oh he was at the Ransom lady over
remember that video mmm he was like
pointing up I remember he hit apparat
see that was trying to it was getting a
little too close to his car maybe he ran
someone over he was yeah he went to like
the Anne Frank memorial and so he would
have been a belieber yeah
but that's just you know in retrospect
yeah it would have been yeah he's like
listen if I was a little younger and I
was born in the 40s out of [ __ ] 10 Frank
so then this is one of my favorites I I
love this video so much and I got a
couple angles here I got to bring up
this is Travis Scott at Drake's a Boy
Meets World Tour and there's another
situation these big holes in the ground
it's a big problem big old big problems
[Laughter]
yeah we just have a have a trapdoor like
that but yeah obviously somebody [ __ ]
up open now did he fall off the stage or
in a hole off something or in something
there's a little middle yeah Wow really
and so the fact that you can auto-tune a
fall supposed to show you how hard
overtime these Auto Tunes are working
yeah Drake is like that's turn
he chose to come help about weighted
that is okay Wow
right she wasn't injured that looked
really bad okay well he actually did a
lot of damage when he fell in that hole
really what happened actually well he
made a statement someone asked him about
it he said I didn't fall dude I flew I
was floating I don't fall
nothing happened floating is amazing and
he said I'm a magician like David Blaine
you know he called it but actually the
let's see this is what they keep in that
hole it's like this big globe was in the
hole it come it like comes out of it and
an inflatable globe thing that Drake
would perform with and he fell on it and
smashed the [ __ ] out of it and Drake did
this whole show for free he had to
refund he refunded everybody just
because of that yeah cuz that's like
such a big piece of the show for the
globe was all right the globe freaking
oh how much you think that would have
cost I mean I don't know close to a
million pauses that's a bit it was like
a huge arena in London yeah that's like
one of the huge ones probably a milli
yeah that ball cost alone blue oh yeah I
wonder if he's still got paid Travis
Scott I don't know I mean Drake probably
wanted to make him fly over oh yeah and
then I think this is one that you put in
here this is that was you
Miguel this is type of billboard musical
Road to me oh yeah oh my god this one
deserves to be slow-mo well let's watch
him once more
Miguel kicks two girls in the face and
he attempts to jump over the crowd and
what he ends up doing is a WWF crotch
slam on a poor girl's face now let's
watch it and almost beat him in back
slow-mo over in stone
this is really something and here you'll
notice and he continued as she sustained
a life-changing injury and he gets close
with the girl who didn't even get bought
yeah that's not her that he hugs she
like pushes the girl that cut hurt out
of the way is like all right yeah let's
go slow-mo on this because this is a
really special moment
let's go court yeah oh you go Court
quarter speed in quarter so here we have
this fateful moment her why he thought
this was great at WWF and body-slammed
what a pro yeah you'll notice that she
falls to the ground yeah with the dark
hair is there yeah and then the blonde
girls likes yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
his music sounds even better Wow and
apparently I found this article or they
said he was told not to do the jump
he asked before if he could and he went
for it anyway
was there any consequence of that
oh hey Philippe I actually I found this
was immediately after backstage he
brought the girl that hit the deck
backstage to apologize this is set up
for a day not the best circumstance like
you know ouch
Raj slammed her his name's yeah she
really really got the brunt of it so
you're still gonna dance to miguel songs
were your big phantom again I'm gonna
put you on the spot were you big fan of
Miguel before he before he jumped on you
apparently she went to the hospital and
was reporting she says she said that she
was having some like memory issues and
stuff but a little or elbow yeah and
then - well two years after this
happened the other girl that got hit
actually did sue him really yeah she
went I couldn't find any yeah that was
yeah you know is it a little messed up
how they like parade her around
afterwards like oh yeah she just hit her
up I mean she may have on a level been
excited like if she really was a fan
it's like okay I'll use this as an
opportunity to
to meet my idol or whatever but but yeah
he was definitely keeping it ambiguous
for legal reasons and description well
that's why I heard representation
he was like instead of taking her to get
her checked out you brought her to go do
a quick interview it was like that you
know we don't really appreciate that
stuff and that was the last of the stage
Falls is it white what what if it
shouldn't be as funny as it is to watch
people yeah it's great because it's well
fun watching someone fall just by itself
is already great but then when you see
like a famous person yeah like these
idols that people look up to that are
like untouchable larger-than-life
falling through a hole in the stage it's
such a contrast shot of Linda I believe
yeah right yeah it's humanizing I guess
in a way just see that they're just
people they eat [ __ ] sometimes
can you remember any bad Falls you had
in front of people that were
embarrassing her mm-hmm because I fell
down a flight of stairs at school once
yeah in front of a lot of others a lot
of yeah I'm about to fall yeah well it
was like it was it was very it was very
icy outside a lot of snow so everyone
was tracking in you know snow and it was
very slippery and I just mm down the
whole thing you know all my ass and
there were a lot of people around so
that was you were embarrassed yeah okay
trauma from it do you think
yeah I'm still emotionally scarred I
can't go up a flight of stairs I mean
seriously was it was it a real it's just
you know when you're in high school
everything is even like everyone's yeah
I per aware of what you're doing
were you injured no no just my pride is
there anyone that you cared about that
witnessed it like a friend or a girl you
were interested in no they're our
friends rowdy ously get roasted a lot
yeah yeah am I the only one that fell
cific like traumatic incident not the
one fall
it wasn't like embarrassing but like my
we were on those trips where they take
the whole class like at the end of the
year
mm-hmm and we were in this one like
kibbutz oh I don't know what it was but
there was someone with like a little
cart pulling like a little open cart I
don't know like something on wheels you
could stand on yeah
and for some reason the whole class
decided to go on it I don't even
remember how it happened
mm-hmm but we all went and stood on this
thing well this guy was driving yeah
this little cart and then he decided to
take a turn and I fell you fell off yeah
just me you almost like you kept going
you didn't realize and he almost like
went over my head stop right there and
we're by your classmates I was more like
I got in trouble because we weren't
supposed to do that and I don't know not
quite sure I have an image in my head of
what happened like there's a car with a
cart yeah and you all got in the back
it's like a little car and like I mean
like a golf cart all right something
like that okay you know yeah and you
were in the golf cart so he was carrying
a thing on the back oh like attachment
okay so it was kind of like an open how
many people were on it like 30 and
you're the one day yeah I'm glad you
survived that Jesus I was just had a
memory of company really embarrassing I
did I didn't fall but the best I can
remember is I was super into yo-yoing I
was mugging yeah I was so insane I
wasn't the leap in it I was cribbing at
yeah and of course my favourite and most
impressive around the world the classic
you go around the world you're still
spinning you're still slamming and so I
was going at the grocery store with my
friend and we were just doing yo-yo with
his friend with the friend did their
parents was grocery shopping and I'm
doing around the world around the world
having a good time and there's an old
lady that I [ __ ]
I guess like that and I didn't see her
she crept up on me
they're slow quiet and I hit it right in
the glasses and her glasses fell off
whoops
you sent her around the world yeah and
you have a neck sprain is that the ex
brain I seem to remember that being like
the cool one I don't remember but it was
one of the good ones yeah sick ass
larynx does it did your school trying
people were always coming to my school
and trying to sell me yo-yos it's not a
thing that did you have that like yo-yo
salesman yeah no my school outlawed
yo-yos because they were being used in
Lincoln yo-yos but the ladies she did
she did she passed on now she was fine
she just yelled at man I was super
embarrassed by the way my story it ended
up also even in an article in a local
news really and the first time I learned
that the media lies because they made of
this whole thing about the driver was
telling us not to go in the thing and it
didn't slow news day yeah well we were
off party Oh what was the headline some
kids a you or this subject
Wow way I think there's an archive you
saved it yeah your parents think about
that I tried to make it seem like less
than it was because I didn't want to get
in trouble
mm-hmm but we were like a way in a
northern area so my parents couldn't
like come and see me or anything they
called your parents to teach her they
called my mom and I was like don't tell
Dad like it's nothing serious and when
you got back home were you in deep [ __ ]
no I think my mom she kept it she I
think I managed to make it seem like not
much happen yeah mom saved your ass and
looking back really not much happen but
I felt like I was gonna get in trouble
yeah when you're a kid that's like death
and death oh yeah
and there you have it that's incredible
what's next on the docket that was it
the next one is ela segment I believe
ela segment so what should we do should
we do a little although I guess you're
there but you're gonna throw it on the
screen no oh she can do it from here
down alright this is we got this no meme
left behind guys you know one thing with
the falling eye and this is this is a
bit of a confession but like this isn't
like a public embarrassment thing this
is more my own shame when I'm alone and
I'm going up the stairs I have like this
weird tendency where I always try and do
it too fast and I like I eat [ __ ] on the
stairs like often but never like I keep
it under wraps if I'm like with other
people yeah exactly like I don't know
why but I'm always like you know when I
get home or something no I mean up the
stairs in my apartment building I'll be
like - stepping it up and just just
full-on just flat on my face
it's happened countless do you think
this is a problem I mean it's kind of a
problem like it it's consistent enough
that I'm aware that it's like a thing
that I eat [ __ ] on so why is it that you
just don't slow down something wrong
with me because again if there's
somebody else around you know I'm not
doing that you're not doing that only by
yourself yeah and have you ever
seriously injured yourself I mean not
seriously no but back
yeah I've bashed my elbow pretty [ __ ]
hard yeah is it a thrill-seeking I guess
or I'm just I'm always extreme yeah just
like can I do it how many stairs gonna
do it one whatever it's such a like
little kid thing it's embarrass see I'm
getting grew fat and out of shape that I
have trouble on stairs just the one
stuff is done one step is thrill safety
all the thrill-seeking I need are we
having issues well guys as we've sedated
nomemes shall be left behind
we are behind Adam e limes we are doing
technical fixes ok ok there you go sir
okay I won't I was trying to save it
all right ela what is your segment what
you got we miss this next story is one
of my favorite stories a corporate
executive led a secret double life as an
Australian Pooh jogger mm-hmm and what
happened is that this guy
The Washington Post democracy dies in
darkness
this guy was he had like a nice job um
sorry this is not used to the W was
actually on the City Council inclusivity
board would you own the city huh
oh yeah you have this in bullet point
thing here yeah yeah and so I don't know
how to do this cuz I can't read it from
that article
yeah just read from this okay so he was
served on the City Council which made
recommendations about how the city
should grow mm-hmm and he had a pretty
high up job he's a well-respected member
of the community
yeah but in an unflattering picture and
that on a public sidewalk in Australia
he recently was discovered as the
infamous
[Laughter]
so I think the story is not staged the
guy that took this picture actually was
planning it for like a year cuz they
kept getting this like human shits on
this and it was like not even it was
clear that it wasn't an accident because
sometimes he would even leave toilet
paper next to the dude he left but he
brought toilet paper with him he went
there to [ __ ] outside yeah wow that's
blessed pre murder premeditated kidding
and so over time the people that lived
in that area we're trying to figure out
like
when he was doing it to find it schedule
is something and then they were trying
to get a picture of him so they could
reveal who it was and it took them about
a year until they figured out like the
time that he was usually doing it and
then they left they tried living like
cameras in the area
I wanted a documentary and eventually
this guy was waiting for him with the
camera and when he was about to snap the
picture there was like a red dot on the
camera and he saw it and looked and took
the picture this is like a true crime
documentary yeah and more like that
what's the show it's like a parody of
the American scandal or whatever vandal
band did he kind of like was it targeted
was he trying to pull on specific
people's neighborhood like their doors
or outside of something real can you see
is not so what let's just assume let's
just say no no yeah I don't think you
can see his nuts but there's I mean
that's a there's a lot going on the same
as Andrew Mackintosh if you're an audio
listener you need to go google this
immediately so what's the what was the
resolution when it clicked to take the
picture he looked at images hello wait
who said hello the pooper hello
and then once this was released they
like it became viral and everyone knew
it was him and he was charged with a
fine of three hundred and seventy eight
dollars oh that's a small price yeah he
lost his job as a bomber yeah it was an
executive you said right he was on the
City Council he was like the public
service
now looks like I just googled his name
he was a corporate executive and on the
city oh it's like very upstanding member
of society in like every way such a
perfect story God where do you go from
there to the sidewalk to there's one
great weed that someone made I want the
food jogger footage narrated by David
David is there a video or just no just
the photo today here you could see you
the Australian puja comes out at 3:00
a.m. and shits on his neighbor's grass
no one has found him in the wild until
now that's a beautiful thing that's it
there you have it ela well very well
described the Pooh jogger we are coming
right along here on nomemes left behind
and we are certainly not these any of
our moms that certainly should not have
been left behind because that any that
was amazed not anymore
yeah you're up next with the wacky and
wild world of World Records so yeah it
would somehow this slipped through the
cracks but even before looking for
content for the show
just like weirdest World Records has
always been really interesting to me
people that like you know demonstrate
some bizarre [ __ ] skill so there's
this is all gonna build up to something
but we'll start a little slow so this
was relatively recently this guy Eli
Bishop held the world record for number
of claps in a minute exciting yeah you
can clap it's called speed clapping and
apparently there's like this whole sub
nine well this is the current champion
is a nine year old whoa this guy who has
dedicated his life to it mr. Eli Bishop
he's like in his 30s or something he got
owned by a nine year old so yeah here's
here's 40
I know get the hell out here Facebook
Wow yeah so this is actually kind of
cool clapping yeah I find that they
shoot it in high speed so they can
actually count each individual cloud guy
and load down
yeah within 60 seconds I was able to fly
up 120 times something he's beating off
superfan yeah it's kind of you don't
know what you're hearing it's a little
odd he's not the world record anymore
cuz this kid this [ __ ] nine year old
so that a nine year old saw that video
and was like wait I can do that well
this guy that guy's like this is all I
have this is all I have
which that's that's like the flip side
to it is like these people that have
these odd skills
wait this kid's name is seven his name
is seven wait wait what was that you
know I was thinking about naming our
first daughter soda because I always
thought that was a cute name episode of
Seinfeld where George wants the names
kids seven and soda one of them still
seven his cousin still seven time but I
this must have been inspired by yeah I
didn't even think about seven well no
wonder he's such a superstars Panther
Seinfeld fans so this kid rocks and yeah
he faster though I can say that yeah but
evidently this they counted this and he
did 1080 so 60 more claps in a second
well well they're doing some kind of it
counts like each percussion of it as
like it I think he's hitting like lower
yeah well everyone at home you want to
your path to stardom is very clear very
simple you just all you got to do is
well there yeah I mean that one's pretty
straightforward but now we'll get into
to the
hmm so this guy Gerard Donny now he
evidently has since broken the record
since this video I'm about to show you
but there is no there's no video of it
it was a Guinness verified thing but
there is apparently a record that exists
he's a giant Isis was on a German
television show we did it most number of
plungers stuck to someone's back
what why it even a category right and so
this is where it starts to get like this
is the beginning of a gay porn I'm sure
so he's not that's the thing not only is
there record for this but the record in
60 seconds which I guess this is more of
just a demonstration but this guy does
have the record and the record is 15
it's not even like a lot right just
throwing [ __ ] at these poor guys I love
that they're all in jeans yeah I gotta
say there's one of the worst things I've
ever seen
yeah this is uh this is definitely a
fetish like their hot little twinks and
they're all in jeans and they're all
wearing motorcycle helmets we got to do
it safely
it's really exciting yeah so this this
is uh this is the the kind of stuff that
you can go down in history for I wonder
how you practice for that like do you
call like your friends me like I need
you first yeah interesting gig
Craigslist interesting gig for an
afternoon right 50 bucks so I need you
to wear these jeans and span topless
what throw plungers at you go I'm into
that no here's the real [ __ ] you know
how do these categories come into
existence I know the Guinness World
Record has all these categories of feats
that you can achieve but how does
something like throwing a plunger at a
dude I thought was that II able to just
pitch it to them can you light your own
record there's an extraordinary thing I
can throw plungers at people and make it
stick to them and unique person to like
pursue something so weird but make it a
Guinness record right what is making me
think I wonder if I have any goodness
where the talents that just haven't been
pitched to them yet right exactly like
times masturbated in one day I wonder if
that is a Guinness World Record
you know I'm gonna probably probably so
I think I may be the they're like 30 I
was like I beat that I'm 50 so this one
now what I found out is that there's
actually competing record organization
Guinness is the famous one of course but
there's also record setter apparently
competitor right a competitor now this
guy is a guy from the Philippines he set
the record for the most lit candles
extinguished by a fart to live
whoa why only six yeah which again it's
like I feel like somebody could do
better somebody out there in the
audience you can be totally one of this
not even a smile this is serious
business don't do it don't do it
yo yo yo is this not just like expert
village we could just send everything yo
can i watch that again yeah yeah we
gotta roll that back so the guys on his
back and he's got like a horn like a
horn up to his [ __ ] and he's doing
power farts on five lit candles and
blowing them out every time boom that
sound is something in it definitely a
finish yeah I'm into it God I come in my
pants every time I hear it because
seriously is his basis so mold is
raishin yeah he's holding his sack by
the way hand on his chode I don't know
what that does but I'm sure it's part of
his superpower at the right angle what I
like that it's just like what
that's incredible I haven't got ten
weird sex records down would you like to
hear yeah let's hear it this is part two
though furthest ejaculation whoa is 19
feet longer than a stretch limo what 19
feet not 18 feet 9 inches now that's a
record yeah most orgasms in one hour
here's the one that I was going for
record is a woman who had 134 what are
is over the course of an hour record for
males just 16 well I've heard of women
who have a disease were they it's
actually like a psychological problem
where they can't stop orgasming and it
seems like torture for them hmm but uh
Silverstein where's the physical proof
with a guy you know you got a little rap
and proving it so you could monitor like
heart rate and think oh maybe they
thought this through but
well forget us world record you know
they take it very seriously what else
you got 16 I feel like I could give that
a run that's the guy our 16 in an hour I
mean that's one every that's pretty
quick that's a lot five minutes or
something no I mean if you think you're
up that you'd hit like 10 and you'd die
in an hour is pretty [ __ ] well your
dick just becomes like super nut all
right yeah sixteen huh
honorable mention is the official
longest orgasm was recorded in 1966 when
a woman had a 45 second orgasm that
involved 25 individual contractions
oh the contractions is probably they're
able to monitor that maybe man who
fathered the most children 69 kids
Oh mrs. vast Sylvia is pregnancy prowess
pales in comparison the multiplying
could you just write this like a normal
person the King of Morocco had between
over his lifespan the king of morocco
fathered at least 1014 children sure the
Genghis Khan probably okay whatever this
stop being interesting guy had an all
right so this all leads me to some of my
favorite videos I've seen on the
Internet in a long time so this was
actually very recent
back in September of this year this guy
in India his name is Naveen Kumar broke
the world record for the most number of
walnuts smashed with your forehead
another really competitive well let me
tell you that I Got News it is very
competitive there are a lot of guys
facing this one yes so so the previous
record he broke this guy did 217 and he
broke the previous record by 36 so
smashed mashed it literally literally
wow this is super power does not start
really ah you vete know oh well it's no
joke and at the end of this video you'll
see I mean his forehead is like oh yeah
no it cannot be good well you know NFL
players have like brain damage their
strength
so imagine smashing your head into a
walnut like the housing pump well it's
worth it for the glory I guess the
grunts I really what makes it good you
don't have to do this I feel like you
lost some speed on that turn they really
should it they got a gonna longer table
you don't have to do this man so right
that was a minute then quite make it the
whole way but shake his hand oh yeah Wow
tall very calm so imagine going through
all that any camera there yeah I mean
Guinness was there and everything like
this was all this was sanctioned now
imagine going through all of that only
to have one month later oh no this is a
super competitive
oh she does seem we should maybe have
Joey cells trying to crack walnuts for
the charity like everyone I he cracks is
like a is like more money that will
don't - yeah but it's amazing
that'll be so good maybe that's a good
one we'll see if he's down Joey's
downtown anything you're literally he
really is especially for the sake of
charity I mean he's got a sweetheart
yeah oh yeah so so not only did so this
guy that the previous guy Naveen did 217
this this guy 32 year old Muhammad
Rashida Nasim managed to he's got a
fancy a table and if you thought that
last guys uh sound effects his efforts
were good you got here this guy now
these tapes to the table guys a genuine
pro you don't have to do this these guys
to practice this a lot too
yeah you'd have to I guess poor guy
right yes he got the right strategy and
focusing his energy much much more
strongly see that holy [ __ ] oh they're
all bloody now he's like oh my god and
gayness approve this think that is
[ __ ] nuts
he was about 115 deep and then just
suddenly every single what he's not
stopping he missed all my job duties
were to do there was one where he missed
the nut and slammed his head on the
table and there was a huge spider blood
warrior this guy's a warrior serious I
don't think there's any cash prize for
it's just the gorila glory glory keep
the walnut luxurious book yeah yeah hard
to watch yeah I did not realize how you
got that sound effects I notice that
gruesome I didn't realize how gruesome
now one god I only discovered this one
this morning because I was trying to
find more info on that other one and saw
the story that I was literally less than
a month later he got completely blown
away by this guy through a true I can't
compete with that know that guy his his
mind and body and health he's all exist
solely to smash those nuts that's why
I'm wondering how do you go rewarded
this guy nut cracks at work yeah what
does he get no no this is his actual
YouTube channel I just realized there he
is
can you show more click somewhere yeah
let's let's see what he has to say about
that
yeah so there's a whole wide world of
this and yeah I don't know like even
though this is hilarious
I find something really interesting
about people that choose to be excellent
at something so stupid you know what I
mean like yeah it's dumb but this guy is
the best person on the planet that's
taking walnuts his forehead yeah
that would make an incredible
documentary do you think people that
pursue
becoming specialized hyper specialize in
these one weird thing your little niche
things yeah that would be amazing man
you got a Dan you have a mission to go
out to I think you guys from Pakistan so
you can't make it woman Joey salads
there's some on on the scene report yeah
we'll have to see if he's uh if he's
good to go
yeah that's it that's that's the wild in
my world I was wonderful in this world
record
wow that was nuts he ain't coming in
strong Wow reporters destroying those
ganas books were my favorite thing Wow
how do I top the nut cracker save that
for the end I'm really enjoying this
very special episode a stream podcast up
and leaving no man behind
mm-hmm having a lot of fun out here you
know it had to be done I had to be
Donna's could not couldn't happen it can
it can well been hidden from the people
the policy of the United States military
is to leave no man behind right and it
is our policy here on this podcast to
leave no mean behind it we didn't have a
choice yeah that we didn't want it I
didn't want to go back so here we have
this is something that I've been working
on and thinking about for a long time
there are these wonderful videos of
reporters destroying ships now the
question that I have when you go deep
down this rabbit hole of these goofy
reporters not walking into ice
sculptures or knocking over whatever on
during live broadcast it's it's always
the same guy kind of or well there is
duplicates and so I'm wondering is this
fake real is this because these are old
clips is this viral
as if it's fake this guy's like a genius
before before it was a thing so yeah let
me get into this here this is the guy in
question worldwide for their bubble
artistry it's attempting to burst a
bubble
world record they hope to set a new
Guinness record for the most people Wow
I meant to do that yeah covering the
bubble story from the inside note the
legend yes David this guy okay and as
you say we are here at the Discovery
Science Center in San an all things
science entertainment education
technology the event going on the next
three weeks here is really unbelievable
no not unbelievable unbelievable and
we're about to explain why all these
good folks here are getting in a giant
sized bubble to try and get the Guinness
record George overhears a lot of moving
parts to introduce you to fan yang who
was under cement fan thank you so much
for being here and what is going on big
fender well this is gonna be a Guinness
world record for the most number of
people inside the bubble we have hundred
and fifty people here right on the
platform to be inside 50 people so far
the world record is 90 people in a
bubble the Guinness all of this that's
correct we have any support I could
judge right there so we are ready to go
how does one get involved in bubbles
what is the dynamic behind all this well
this all come from my childhood I was
fascinated about the bubble spot in the
surface of the river when I was six
years old and then when I was 18 years I
start to experiment as various liquid
solution just to make the largest
possible box amateur and do I understand
correctly you've been working on this
for years and it's some sort of secret
mixture 70% water and 30% you don't like
to tell I have explored the wall above
us over the past 27 years solution
is 70% sister special secret ingredients
we have to make it right
thank you George this way I want to
introduce you to Erin Rhodes Erin with a
Discovery Science Center thank you for
being here you're welcome Erin why is
this important obviously it's fun and
festivities but what is the deal with
science and bubbles it is tried to
combine science I mean all science
center thank you feels very real thank
you do this thing now fan are you ready
to get your world record just to give us
a sign time they step back thank you so
we're ready to go and can you just step
little bit back to him yes yes
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
he's depth in the pool he broke the
bubble he burst above and they only have
one chance he said although I don't know
why you don't have
[Music]
snow is very reliable send it back to
you sorry oh my god they're always
believably good it ok so I have a theory
tim heidecker moment these apologize the
new thang yeah
I'm sorry and we'll send it back to you
sorry okay so there you have it looks
real I have a feeling it's fake
really I'd like the one time only things
seems suspicious to me
now why would you only be able to do it
once okay okay there's an explanation
onto Exhibit B and thank you for
supporting me in this pursuit now go
fast-forward to another reporter goofs
and what do you know it's the same
reporter another live broadcast with an
ice sculpture okay yeah I saw that first
video I was like wow this is incredible
this is real this is real stuff when I
saw this clip I threw everything under
question and there we go
your prized possessions oh yeah this is
a cherub it's actually been a very tough
piece to do we've been working on it for
about eight hours right now we still got
quite a ways to go on to the beautiful
Agility's yes now can I take a closer
look at this because why is this your
problem we'll talk to management fake or
not it's [ __ ] hilarious
but watch his hand okay now he puts his
hand and he seems to really push it I
love how he puts the mic in his face
like they get his answer I'm so sorry it
was just an accident
we'll talk to management I will get this
taken care of my face will send it back
to you that's the same guy yeah so one
theory that I've worked on is that the
first one was real yeah second one was a
fake to try to turn it in
- a thing oh that's interesting that's
his thing right that being said the
first one there seemed to be a lot more
humiliation and shame and there's so
much with all the build-up - yeah
exactly and there was tons of people
there that's just some local news
channels so yeah in there are a lot of
moving parts if he did you know it's
pretty impressive it's a big effort just
for a little gag regardless it is
fascinating I think what you said I
think I think the original probably was
real and then it just became his
signature thing to [ __ ] [ __ ] up because
he had the way he handled it the second
time was very different although he is a
pro at this point of ruining thanks but
now I have a bonus a bonus clip for you
and you can tell me if you think this
one is real or fake it is another
classic they don't pay real you know you
have to pay great
that's right we were trying to get a
Guinness person out for something we did
what was it debate number of shirts
oh no the vain we we wanted to make like
the biggest vape oh alright the thing is
you have to pay them to come out right
which I guess makes sense so tell me
these people look pretty broken that's
like the nut they spent like their life
saving I don't know of table I don't
think that was a Guinness though the not
one no it was it was it was yeah yeah
they had the banner behind
oh yeah no they were that was officially
sanctioned I'm almost made to be there
mm-hmm
but that being said we've got really
classic this is the lassic for your
entertainment and judge that I really
want to show you is right over here this
is the Leaning Tower of Pisa and our
campus here and the person that's built
is right around the corner here
those cables wrapped around brian barn
1990 graduate of northern and he's going
to tell us a little bit about this
amazing structure well it's as you can
see the Leaning Tower of Pisa it's about
twelve thousand blocks it took over two
weekends to build and I'm really excited
because next week the Guinness Book of
World Records team are going to come to
evaluate it no I think if it's fake that
they built it had the purpose of it and
well they wanted to you know have a gag
while destroying it but oh my god either
way I mean yeah it's a joy to behold it
either way okay
so what else we got here um we've got a
bunch of leftover videos and stuff but
everyone's done their segments we've
saved a lot of memes here today yeah
we've done a service we've I feel like
we all deserve a Purple Heart well we
did it we did it
it's good we Came we saw we went to war
we went behind enemy lines and we've
saved some really valuable worthy man
pulled him out of the [ __ ] yeah that was
special
so thank you guys joining us on this
special episode of uh no meme left
behind we will be back on Friday as
usual next Friday bill works is here
very excited about yeah yeah and thank
you so much to the illustrious day named
Ian of course who thank you with whom
the show would not be the same
without true can I say that yeah I would
say that fact for better for worse yeah
so Ian I want to get back to something
you were a fan when you joined yeah but
are you still a fan yeah you hate me now
that you've will a fan I do still enjoy
it okay well I have to watch every
episode and I don't hate it yeah I don't
hate Duke so that's the best a line
that's the best you can say about this
Potter guest I don't hate it
thank you alright guys see you on Friday
have a great Thanksgiving bye yeah
that's true and have a big life in fact
I'm gonna step it up have a blessed
giving Wow continue to send us and
submissions podcasted hav Britain to
come yeah we got some good ones good you
guys plan on breaking a Guinness World
Record save some money I'll come and the
the charity one that's first and I think
Joey salesmen I'm gonna ask if he wants
to crack some walnuts with his head
because that'd be amazing I'll give a
shot to one oh I think I'm gonna regret
that
do you think I don't have I don't think
I have the will to overcome the urge to
not slam your head into it yeah not as
hard as you can
yeah and I think if you if you hesitate
at all it's gonna hurt way worse it's
like breaking a board if you've ever
done that like if you if you pull your
punch at all you break your knuckles but
if you just go for really real good yeah
yeah boy howdy I break boards all the
time alrighty thank you guys for
watching and we shall see you on the
next episode of Friday happy
Thanksgiving everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]